We're asked to reflect
this line across the line y
is equal to negative 4.
So you have this
line right over here,
and they actually give us all
of these transformation tools
right over here where
we can Translate,
Rotate, Reflect, Dilate, or
Undo what we were about to do.
So they want us to
reflect this line across y
is equal to negative 4.
So let's get the
Reflection tool out.
So I clicked reflect and
let's make this line be y
equals negative 4.
So let's see.
That would look something
y equals negative 4.
So we're going to reflect
this line across y
equals negative 4.
So let's reflect it,
and there you have it.
We reflected it across
y equals negative 4.
And then they ask us to
answer some questions.
When a line is reflected,
the image created is a line.
We know this is true because
a reflected image, well,
the original image
had zero endpoints.
These are just two points on
the line, they're not endpoints,
they're not defining
the end of the line.
If they were both endpoints
it would be a line segment,
but this line keeps
going in both directions.
So we know this is true
because a reflected image has
zero endpoints, and
we got it right.